I'm with the president of the iou dr.
bilal philips for those that don't know
and we're gonna be talking about many
different things one of them i wanted to
start off with your reaction [ __ ] to the
netflix they have a film I believe it's
called something about the Messiah and
people linking it to the job did you get
a chance now to look at the trailer and
what was your first reaction when you
saw that I did see the trailer somebody
sent it to me and I mean it's to be
expected this is just a matter of time
you know before it came I mean they did
the Christ thing before you know
what's-his-name from Australia you know
he did the Passion of Christ email
Gibson yeah Passion of the Christ
good Gibson and before that there was
Jesus Christ Superstar and of course
that was that you know he was portrayed
as a homosexual and you know it was
offensive to a lot of people etc but I
mean this is to be expected that this is
a key figure in you know in in the West
who from time to time they're going to
bring things out to revive the churches
are emptying you know so what can bring
people back stir them touch them you
know so that efforts gonna be there hmm
what it when you mentioned the job for
those people who've never heard this
term what is the Islamic concept what is
how does Islam view this what's the
definition of it what is it what does
this term mean for people just to really
have no clue well the term dejar coming
from dead Gela you know it means false
and it has been translated when they
talk about al-maseeh at that job
bringing the two together Messiah being
the Messiah
it means the false messiah or the false
Christ or
they you know the the Antichrist is the
the common term which is used in
Christian theology and eschatology you
know this Antichrist the false Christ
because obviously the Antichrist as a
limitation so the Antichrist means been
talked about in Jewish Scriptures early
Jewish Scriptures it was developed in
the Christian scriptures to lululu
to become an actual figure in the Jewish
Scriptures they they identified some
pagan rulers as Antichrist and in
Christian scriptures they identified
also rulers of different eras they even
you know in the the time of the
Reformation at such a they identified
the Pope's you know the papacy as being
the Antichrist so they and then they
have descriptions of the the individual
and what he's gonna do they have you
know that's been in their in their
theological descriptions over the years
you know taking on many different forms
but of course it's not based on on
revelation you know it's surmise I mean
obviously the idea of the the job you
know is based on Revelation Prophet
Muhammad SAW Solomon said that you know
every single prophet who preceded him
warned his people about the dead job so
we know that it is based in Revelation
ultimately but you know in time it gets
distorted warped you know the clear
picture of it is not there it's only in
Islamic scriptures you can find a clear
crystal clear description of that job
you know right down to his eyeballs you
know what is he actually look like and
his his bill
descriptions are there you know all the
details there then when he's gonna come
where it's gonna come from you know
who's gonna follow him you know when he
when he he comes what kind of a a fitna
or trial he will he be for humankind and
the promise of Sodom has said that you
know that between his time and and the
the ending of the world or even from the
time of Adam actually from the time of
Adam to the ending of the world there
has been or will be no greater trial for
humankind than at the jail the
Antichrist
so you mentioned share dr. Bluhm that
you we see this with every messenger
that the Creator sent one that they all
came with the same message worship the
one God the Creator not the creation and
they also warned about the Anti Christ
every one of them every last one of them
do you hear that
how do you how do you what's your
reaction when you hear a lot of some
people who are misinformed some hey
provocateurs some people who have just
been misled when they tried to attribute
this term Antichrist to Muslims well you
know it's it's natural that the concept
of Antichrist became anyone who did not
believe in Jesus's divinity you know so
the the greatest you could say religious
movement which specifically denied the
divinity of Christ for them that
represented the Antichrist so Muhammad
may God's peace and blessings be upon
him was labeled in their circles as the
Antichrist so those who follow him are
following the Antichrist this is you
know there was a period
I'm especially during the time of the
Crusades you know when they wanted to
drum up that people to come and fight in
in Palestine in in the in the you know
the that region in Jerusalem etc to take
ticket back from the Muslims as they
said they did to motivate those people
to come travel thousands of miles across
Europe from all the way from the UK on
foot to come there and fight give up
their lives they motivated was one of
the things that they used to motivate
them to come and and and and and make
that massive sacrifice you know that
they were fighting against the Anti
Christ the followers of the Antichrist
but if you just break down if you see
Antichrist Christ meaning the Messiah
right this is uh if you try to be Greek
from Messiah you know Messiah when it
goes into Greek it ends up as Christos
you know so now for us to be Antichrist
that would be anti Jesus but that would
just take us out of Islam that would
that's something that goes against the
tenets of Islam we have to believe in
the Messiah in Jesus not as a god or a
literal son of God so anybody who just
does a little bit of super vicious
superficial or just top of the surface
homework they'll see that this is just
totally a false yeah it's not Christians
are under the impression that we as
Muslims don't even believe in Jesus you
know we consider him to be fake that
there was no Jesus there was no you know
person by that name or whatever or we
rejected Jesus but in fact you know
Islam embraces Jesus you know Jesus is
the prophet who came before prophet the
last of the prophets Prophet Muhammad
may God's peace and blessings be on both
of them so you know it's a part of our
own faith
you know it's a part of our own faith to
believe in Jesus if a one says he
doesn't believe in Jesus this you know
we have some breakaway heretical sects
you know that claim that you know Jesus
is not coming back
you know the Ahmadiyya for example Mirza
Ghulam Ahmed back in the 1800s you know
he claimed he was the Jesus that people
were waiting for and then you had others
who made this type of claim you know
before and after the the film seems like
it's going in these regions like in
Yemen and some and these places
Jerusalem and it seems like it takes
this actor in these different places and
also I believe his name was something
with connected with MACD so do you think
they studied some of the Islamic sources
what do you what do you think when when
they put this out they would have to
because you mentioned there's nothing
more detailed of this topic than the
Islamic sources is that correct yeah I
mean that is that's not just surmise you
know otherwise you've got people who
have come up with all kinds of crazy
stuff from themselves but to that you
can say trace back to ancient sources
you know because you're talking about
the Quran and the the teachings of
prophet mohammed assalam recorded you
know that's 1400 years ago so this is
ancient very you know so to draw go in
there and draw bits and pieces from here
there and everywhere to put together
this you know semi historical fiction
type movie it makes sense that they
would do that part of their homework so
they probably Netflix and them whoever
they producers they probably went into
looking at the Islamic sources no III
yeah why wouldn't it make sense that
they would yeah and then when when you
look at such films what do you I mean
what do you what do you think like these
topics that are now coming up what do
you think the subliminal messages that
they try to send I mean just from your
experience what would
you'd pinpoint what would you say well
you know when I see anything of this
nature I just think we Muslims are
sleeping man you know we should have put
it out you know we should have put out
something on that job why not yeah you
know something with topic which is you
know appealing to people they like this
you know so it's you know I mean
whenever I I go anywhere and I give a
talk the jaw you know people flock you
know the it's something which which
which it becomes particularly attractive
to people because you know we like the
supernatural and yeah you know this you
know super heroes and and then all of
our kids you know you know especially in
the West etc they all know you know the
arch enemy of Superman the arch enemy of
spider-man then all the time telling me
of all these different men but you know
if you ask them what well what about the
Antichrist
they have no idea ah I mean this is
common in many most places today they
don't know you know that they don't
teach the children instead they will ya
let them play there know you know loser
and they know this one and that one but
the Islamic superhero the arch enemy of
humankind not just of one superhero but
of all of humankind
who is coming you know with a with a
message which is gonna blow people out
of the water
are there some minor signs for the stage
to be set for this Antichrist Dajjal to
come that you could share with us well
in terms of minor science we know that
the Mahdi will come before the Mahdi who
the Prophet SAW Solomon described as
someone having the same his name and
this father's name you know and who
would change overnight so it's not
somebody who would everyone
I knew from the time he was born this is
the MACD we've seen I mean we've heard
him know he's gonna change you know in
in in in a relatively short space of
time and he is going to lead Muslim
forces in confrontation with Rome this
is described as as Rome right but it
means meaning the West because they
represented the Western world so there
would be that Armageddon which which the
Christians speak about and and Muslims
will defeat these forces yeah and this
is this is you could say the second
first second basic signs you know that
this is gonna have to happen I'll get it
I'm a gay internist and have to happen
you know the Ahmadi is going to come the
forces will defeat the forces of of
Western civilization and Constantinople
will be taken for a second time you know
meaning that cause I'm obviously before
that it's gonna be taken away from us
but it will be retaken in that period of
time so there's about four or five
different signs that you know we could
call those minor signs but you know
still Armageddon is not mine yes major
well it's minor relative to that job do
you do we see now some minor or major
signs that already happened no no I
don't believe this nothing like a pea a
piece like that would predict that it's
closer to actually happening because a
certain thing has passed you know people
people thought when the Mongols hit the
most
world and devastated the Muslim world
and you know people thought this was it
you know it's coming
I mean they just wiped out yeah huge
region cities towns villages you know
they're just devastated so people
thought latest around that time it's
coming that Jarl is no just around the
corner but you know people every era
every change of the set and tree you
know people are thinking I the idea
starts to to circulate and people get
worked up and you know caught up in in
this you could say you know some
positions really we don't when the clear
science because promise or something was
very specific yeah you know it wasn't
like vague I mean of course who the
Mahdi is I mean he is he's made is
explain that it is gonna be relatively
vague in the sense that it's not
somebody as we said who from the time
he's born everybody saying look at the
sky you know this is so different and
you know so so you're not surprised when
he turns out to be the math you know I
mean not as it's told in a Shiite
sources you know we're you know it's
it's coming out of a cave or whatever
you know they have this their set of
stories to but you know it's not based
on revelations just suppositions so the
point in you know from the Islamic
perspective it's going to be you know
it's going to follow as the problem
described so without Armageddon the job
is not around the corner I mean actually
there are bigger signs coming then the
Armageddon when the drought begins in
the world you know something might think
well okay now this is the climate change
this is here here it's around
corner you know where problems are
Solomon said the first year before the
coming of the final coming of the job
you know one third of the earth would
not experience any rain the second year
two thirds of the earth
no rain third year no rain anywhere on
earth when that comes know that the job
is around the corner so this process of
this this development it will take place
within the context of the Armageddon and
the Mahdi you know whether it overlaps
clearly overlapping meaning back it's in
the second year we don't know the
problems also didn't give that detail
but we know that this was going to take
place before and so is this one they may
overlap you you being also a former
Christian and someone who met as many
would would consider somewhat of an
expert in in the Bible I mean how much
of it when you compare the talk about it
in Islam compared to in the Bible how
much is there of this Antichrist spoken
about compared to as it is in the Quran
and the Sunnah in Islamic sources well
in the Islamic sources this far more
information you know direct explanations
given by Prophet Muhammad may God's
peace and blessings be upon him which
end up being a part of our scriptural
tradition you know I mean this there's
the actual scripture the Quran itself
and then the explanations which the
Prophet may God's peace and blessing be
upon him gave you know so
both of these sources you know come
together what we have about the the the
Antichrist this is mainly from the the
Sunnah or the explanations of Prophet
Muhammad SAW moral Salaam there is
overlapping in that after the coming of
Christ and the defeat of the Antichrist
Dajjal the it would be followed by the
God and the may God and this is in
Christian literature also and that's
mentioned in the Quran the gog and magog
you know they're mentioned by name in
the Quran itself as well as
circumstances you know regarding them
being walled in yeah what out of the
rest of the world does this have to also
intertwine with what they have of the
rapture
well the rapture is I think we don't
have any anything to support the that
concept we have texts from the Prophet
may God's peace and must be upon him
after after the time of the job the jobs
defeated gog and magog come they tried
to attack prophet jesus prophet jesus
and his people they are able to escape
them and Allah destroys the gog and
magog you know after their you know
devastation of much of the earth he
destroys them himself and then the time
would come after that where Jesus would
rule make Hajj and with his death the
ending signs the signs of the ending of
the world will
come rapidly after that and one of those
signs is that the believers would be
would be their souls would be taken from
the earth so that all the people who are
left on the earth spread by the time of
the the actual Day of Judgment comes all
of them would be evil people all the
believers would their souls would have
been taken in what would be like a
rapture so that you can connect that
there's some similarity they're there
because they believe the rapture is with
all the believing you know people who
believe in Jesus they'll be taken up
right so we have so if you connect this
yeah yeah but here we can say like
helping because we know a lot of the
text there a lot of you have anonymous
books you have you know a lot of
speculation here if the Christian wants
to go above and beyond and really look
into authentic sources and you and you
explain like what the true believers are
believe you know believing in Jesus is
real mission who he was who he wasn't
and putting him in the right context not
as some people have taken him as a
literal guy son of God etc this would
make sense then the way that your that
Islam is describing him yeah because
it's gonna follow you know the time of
Jesus's reign when Jesus you know we'll
we'll finish off you know the issues of
the Trinity it will be ended yeah you
know he would be the the end of that
series of misguidance you know satanic
deviation and delusion of people into
actually believing that Jesus a prophet
of God may God's peace and blessings be
upon him was God himself
you know that's as as great a delusion
as the delusion that the the Antichrist
Dajjal Messiah has the job would try to
put over on people that he
was God yeah you know that's what he
would be trying to sell people and you
know in his case he would have with him
the kind of evidences which would blow
people's minds and make them accept that
you know if they don't have correct
faith you know then they will be easily
sucked into that call of the job yeah
where where the job now portrays himself
as God he cuts people in half and there
and walk within their halves and they
come back together he could say this is
uh you know what's his name angel what's
his name these are the magicians
Christian rock yeah Chris Wayne Twain or
I know what your time I ain't Criss
Angel
so he will have the harvest come back
together but you know he will he will
put two people that if I bring people
whose parents are dead if I bring your
father and mother back to life yeah
would you accept me as God and people
these are even people who supposed to be
believers supposed to be Muslims you
know and and they will say yeah sure if
you're able to bring my parents back to
life
you got to be God and he wouldn't do it
you know she wasn't bringing their
parents back to life with really jinns
you know from the world of the jinn the
spirit world that would enter into our
world take the form of their parents and
that people's parents and would tell
their sons and daughters believe in him
he is God and people will accept it and
it accept him as God yeah so you know
that's a serious test and trial for the
faith of people at that time
so Jesus asylum Jesus peace be upon him
who obviously as Muslims we love is one
of the greatest messengers ever sent to
mankind who came with that same message
as all the other prophets worship the
One God along without associates or
partners believe in him and you at what
point does he fit into this when we talk
about the jowl again what point does he
fit into all this
well you know the point is when when the
jowl shows up and he appears on the
scene and people are flocking behind him
and the then then this the forces of the
Mahdi right after the defeat of the
Western civilization's forces when the
feat takes place then he and and the
others who those were with him they will
end up in Jerusalem they will end up in
Jerusalem and the jaw will have driven
the Mahdi and those who are with him
driven wiping out the armies that had
come together behind the Mahdi the jail
and his forces now would be defeating
them left and right as the odds are
going on around the earth because he is
moving all over the place you know at
the same time he's you know defeating
the forces of the Maddie and Maddie and
his food and those that were remained
with him ended up in Jerusalem and in
the in for the Fajr prayer you know when
he is to lead them Jesus will enter
Jerusalem and people everybody those
steps back for him to to lead the prayer
and he will insist that the Mahdi go
ahead and lead the prayer so this is
where he comes
so at this point now the gel and his
forces reached Jerusalem and are about
to break into the the city and Jesus
will now lead the forces taking the
leadership of the forces the Mahdi will
be behind him and the others and they
will go to meet the jail and his forces
Jesus will spot him in the midst of his
people and go after him because as soon
as the jail sees him he starts to flee
and Jesus will catch up with him and
killed him using some kind of a spear
you know he would he would finish him
off and hold it upright you know to
confirm to the people that the jail was
killed so not only do we believe in
Jesus peace be upon him is one of the
greatest messengers the Messiah but also
that he will defeat the Antichrist there
absolutely that's another one of the
beliefs that we believe in and we also
believe obviously through all this is
because they offer talk about his second
coming so this is another point of
commonality that we also as Muslims
believe that Jesus like you just
describing is coming back mm-hmm
absolutely so there's a lot there in
common there's a lot there in common a
lot a lot of talking points and I'm
surprised that a lot of this hate you
know it gets perpetuated when there's so
much in common between us and the
Christians yes unfortunately but you
know this is the media ya know the media
that's what sells newspapers that's what
attracts viewers you know the demonizing
the Muslim world and its people that's
what sells you would be so surprised how
much Tony
I had a Christian on not too long ago
and he had a really good far large
following and his followers were
listening to our dialogue back
for we had a very nice conversation and
he went from bashing Islam talking
really negatively about problem Muhammad
peace is supposed to be upon him and
other things then he just had an
awakening he really saw like look at
these people they the way they show
reverence to Jesus they say peace be
upon him after his name you know others
will condemn him to the depths of Hell
fire and we're good friends with them
and all these other you know things that
are out there and he just started to do
a little bit of homework and he saw a
while you know why am I gonna hate these
people you know and just from our
conversation those people who had and
some of their comments ranged from man I
had this stem of hate for 20-some years
and just from watching you and this
Christian and Muslim us talk you know
this has really helped to open my eyes
so how powerful just that communication
between us and a good conversation and
pointing out these similarities went a
long way with so many of his followers
yeah this is how it is for many many
people you know I've seen so many you
know occasions I've been present I've
talked with people you know and and and
seeing that Awakening you know I
remember this it went in the way when
we're involved in this exhibition and
people were coming and we were
explaining Islam to them many you know
foreigners not you know non-muslims were
tourists visiting the country and I
remember this this lady coming in and
you know I was giving an explanation you
know about the the the difference you
know between the Christian concept
concerning Jesus and the Muslim concept
you know I just gave a simple example
and I was just saying that you know
basically the child of a dog is a puppy
the child of a cats is a kitten the
child of a cow with a calf then what is
the child of God
right it's got to be another God a
little God because that's what the calf
is is a little cow yes what the kitchen
is a little cat so you have another God
you got that a big goddamn age of the
God and you have another God they're not
the same uh-huh you know so she said at
that point a bulb went off in her head
the light bulb went on hey yeah that's
what that means you know it's not God is
not a man you know God is not a man so
so God if he's gonna have a child it's
got to be another God that's what makes
sense you know so but then their belief
says no you know Jesus was a man you
know God had a son who was a man and
that son was himself this is total
confusion total confusion but for her
that that you know comparison just it
turns something on the bulb
ya know ya just I just never thought
about that yeah that was it she accepted
Islam right on the spot Wow subhanAllah
and for those people that don't know who
are tuned in Islam simply means to
acquire peace by submitting to the
Creator that happens in heard the one
God the same God that Jesus worshiped
the same guy that Moses Abraham the last
and final messenger prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon them all
they all came like you said Sheikh they
all taught the pure monotheism and this
topic that we're talking about that got
us talking about it more was the Netflix
film and do you think that's some good
we can look at it from this aspect that
now it's kind of is it good that we talk
about this topic is it good is it is an
encourage in Islam to talk more about
this topic of the job because it reminds
us of the hereafter the day of judgment
and the things that are coming to to
pass in the future and to take the
departure our departure date often
people think about the birthdays but
they forget about their departure day
you know so these things today it
to talk about it to remind us of you
know not getting so attached to this
temporary temporal world and prepare for
what's coming next
definitely this is you know as we said
most Muslims have very little knowledge
about the job but they know about the
superheroes and the arch you know right
enemies and so this this is something we
lost we should be the one who are
putting out you know an excellent movie
on the job bringing the truth bringing
the truth because we have we have all
the descriptions we have all the the
things related to it you know all the
information and that that would make a
you know quite a movie yeah should you
mentioned are these superheroes that
people take it superheroes you know the
spider-man's and the Batman's and all
that and you see a lot of parents you as
an educator what do you think now should
people should the parents replace these
well you have the basketball stars
they'll have the flash cards you know
and they'll be giving them to their kids
what do you think when you see this
should they be replaced with some of our
superheroes or topics of Dajjal what do
you think about this you know we have
all we have more than enough material to
provide our kids with the excitement and
with the intrigue and the mystery and
all of that we have it you know just
but unfortunately the media is dominated
with the Western view yeah the Western
fairy tales and stuff they you know
turned into movies and those kind of
things so you know it has dominated the
world yeah and this is part of the
struggle that the Muslim world is faced
with but you know more and more I mean
I've seen some cartoon movies for
example made on salahuddin good very
powerful what was done to be produced in
Malaysia I believe in it was you know
one the Gulf states
and pay for it whatever yeah they
produced series on salahuddin you know
which is very attractive to young people
etcetera and it's true yeah you know
exciting it was you know had all this
stuff but it and it's true it's you know
it's true story yeah and we there's so
much more that the that could be
produced and should be produced because
you you're you are telling when you're
telling the truth when you're using this
you know to provide entertainment etc
the truth to telling I mean that that
gives it even a deeper impact yeah you
know for for most I mean they should see
it they should know it they should be
aware of it yeah
then what's out there so you're saying
that we should have got ahead of the
game and put something out on the jael
ourselves that's interesting that Turkey
has taken a lead on some of these films
you had out there go had a really big
profound impact on so many people even a
lot of not yet Muslims out there they
were so like amazed I think the lead the
one of the president of Venezuela I
think it was or other places they were
really captivated by this series they
have the awesome on and what I what are
your opinions on this needed to be done
I mean actually Gadhafi was the first
one to actually do it when he did that
you know Messenger of Allah Muhammad
Messenger of Allah when you want which
one would Anthony Quinn yeah he did yeah
he bankrolled the whole way that's the
that's like the legendary film that film
like it was in a VHS cassettes two parts
yeah Gaddafi he he led the way he made
that Sunnah but you know people didn't
really follow it as they should have
I mean more should have been made more
information about you know because they
they
that you know that was a time actually
it was big contention about whether you
know some of the Sahaba could be seen
and you know Bilal and you know their
issues right and allows her was
consulted and they did the consultation
before doing the movie and you know
there's some controversy but the number
of people that I know who accepted Islam
after watching that movie is huge yeah
and that's not yeah yeah this is the
leading leading one of the leading you
know factors for people accepting Islam
you know after the Malcolm X in the u.s.
you know is that movie yeah that was an
epic film and that's that was that's SD
we need a new HD now version we need
some more coming some some new Islamic
films with that son that that moral
message that you know they just had
something that I we saw recently they're
coming out with these crazy films
Christians were very offended just
recently you mentioned the film about
Jesus I think there's an older one they
got a new one they got like a million
plus signatures to protest this this was
made in Brazil illustrate they were
portraying Jesus peace be upon him as as
a homosexual in this film and I was
saying just as they have a right to be
offended we also take strong offense
because obvious when someone portrays
Prophet Muhammad peace and buzzer
department- right but we also just is
right Jesus is a part of Islam we also
take strong offense mmm yeah the old one
was the same thing this is a new one
that just this is a surprise superstar
this you know back in the I think the
70s or late 70s this one's not even out
this was coming out so this is a new one
yeah so this is uh and this is real
important like you said to counter that
there we got all this money all this oil
you got all these resources I mean if we
took a little part of that put it
towards the Dawa that would be great
wouldn't it really really and they
recently I remember seeing some things
on
YouTube or television with Erdogan and
maja tear and and Imran Khan you know
coming together and saying that they
needed to develop you know a unified
television station to project the
correct you know image of Islam you know
globally when they this should have been
done you know like dr zakir naik he's
doing this is a one-man job is done
masha'Allah Allah bless him for the
efforts that he is made you know this
should have been done by Muslim nations
he was doing something that a nation
needs to be doing they can afford to put
the kind of millions that we needed to
get this thing done but you know he it
should have been followed up with many
other stations inshallah
some people some people can be let to
watch our talk now and get inspired to
go and do something good and put
together some films and you know get out
there in this industry and you know get
the true message of pure monotheism out
the moral message of goodness that's out
there that all these these these are the
true heroes the legends these men that
God Almighty sent to guide humanity to
the truth and I was thinking about
because during this time of the jail and
all this stuff happening you wonder how
many house so many people can get misled
but if you haven't been awoken if you
just been spending all your time you
know just watching movies and
entertainment going to nightclubs and
just you know kickin it and not really
taking life and the purpose of life
serious then no wonder you're gonna when
this all comes to fruition you're gonna
be trapped tricked yeah sure I mean and
the people have been tricked before you
know you have what's his name Jimmy
Jones yeah you know yeah you know way
back in in the 70s
taking 700 of his followers to Guyana
South American getting them to commit
suicide you know I mean they were
believing he was God you know you had
father divine in New York City
he he he had followers a Mamie
and his followers were not allowed to
get fired eventually he got married and
you know his wife from Canada you know
he he called her mother divine you know
they have a part eyes they're in New
Jersey and hey you know people get
suckered into this stuff you know with
ignorance where there is ignorance and
people coming at the time when people
are in need you know this is the the
real trial that can you know bring
people to their knees isn't to accept
these kinds of things and then this is
one of the things that you know the gel
he will be known when he when he comes
into an area it will have with him you
know a mountain of meat and bread you
know and and and we're and where people
are starving because of the drought the
world global drought you know where
people are starving there they can't
find anything to eat and he's coming
with you know mountains of bread and
meat hey that's the test you know your
faith how strong is your faith when
you're dying
your family is dying starving right next
to you and this man says okay you need
I'll make the treasures of the earth
come out for you
yeah here is the food here is the meat
here is the water you know what he will
provide you cause the sky to rain appear
to cause the skies or anyone actually
but he will that build up that's how it
will appear to them you know tell the
sky rain and rain will fall well this is
by Allah's will
it's proud of the tests but this is the
this is the challenge that we're faced
with you know in word we know where does
the the faith reside it resides in the
heart in the mind whether there is real
knowledge where people's faith is based
on fake knowledge
a false information then it may be very
enthusiastic but that faith can easily
be broken down and that's what happens
with the charlatans who trap people drag
them into you know mass suicides and
things like this you know because their
faith is not based on real knowledge you
know so you can easily slip in and offer
them things that you'll appeal to their
their desires or whatever and trap them
yeah so thank you say thank you very
much
tell us how for people you as I
mentioned earlier you're the director
founder of the IOU if people want to
take some classes sign up how can they
do so well this is quite simple oh you
know you it's on University Islamic
online university also known as the
International Open University they just
have to go online you know W wiu.edu dot
GM and we offer there Sharia in English
medium we have Arabic also bachelors
programs master's programs and then we
also have modern studies of education
psychology banking and finance
information technology business
administration but everything is taught
from an Islamic perspective a
comparative perspective where we look at
what these subjects have as content as
it comes from the West because they are
the leaders now in education but then we
look at where Islam differs Islam has
another point of view and another
approach to some of these topics in
different areas of these different
topics and Muslims should be aware you
know because we're learning being
blindly mostly in the university they
just taught
people just swallow it and it just
becomes fact you know like Darwin's
theory of evolution you know for people
in fact we read it enough times we heard
it enough times you've seen it we ever
seen moo-hoo pleased about it you know
how a man oh man
you know evolved from a monkey if you
know Planet of the Apes or whatever you
know we've seen it we've we've
experienced it we believe it it's
reality but it's not it's just a story
his story
yeah his story yeah we started off with
the topic of because of this Netflix
series of the Dajjal do you have also
you also have the four years six years
you have the the the the non diploma
classes also and I think do you have
something on the Dajjal if people wanted
to learn more about this topic or
specific lectures courses well in terms
of the job and details I mean the on
YouTube in my youtube channel you know
AAB Philips yeah there is a series of
lectures that they're there on the dead
job okay so people can get to get more
informed on it to a really anything they
can go check it out there okay thank you
so much it's really honor and pleasure
to have you again it's been a while it's
good to be reconnected and have you on
the program underneath show okay my
pleasure
I'm the LA we need to connect in in
Bosnia and Charla yes
okay now the alaikum salam' rough cut